welcome to Vienna the capital of Austria
in Malaya Hill the city's sixth
municipal district there's a market that
features gourmet specialties from around
the world but those who prefer something
a bit hard here go a little further to
pick up a typical VN a snack a special
sausage known as Kaiser China
Aoife is Viennese through and through a
sausage stand is practically her second
home it's been here for 65 years it's
old Vienna in the truest sense of the
word a sausage stand I came here with my
grandfather
the locals loved Kaiser China mostly
because of the melted cheese inside his
it kinda liked so much in Vienna mixed
sausage meat beef and pork and people
like it especially in the later hours
it's usually served with hot mustard
maybe hot peppers pickles or a good
horseradish
you're falling on tickets before you
start your night out do you look around
for a good sausage stand nice and greasy
filled with cheese then you're ready for
the night when you need a break get
another sausage it's the best thing for
your stomach so you can go from stand to
stand bar to bar it's best with
horseradish because that keeps you fit
all night and Ava won't be turning off
the lights at her stand until the Sun
starts to rise